Hello, my name is Sherri Niziolek and I'm going to have a conversation with Alyson Bernhardt
Alyson Bernhardt. We're at Visible Lives, An Oral History Project at the New York Public Library.
It is October 3rd, 2015 and this is being recorded
recorded at the New York Public Library
Library. So, um
So, um, [suck teet] how are you doing today, Alyson? Good, how are you? Thanks for taking time to
speak with name about the Visible Lives Project. Um, why don't we start with just
Tell me a little bit about yourself--where you came from, where you grew up.
Okay. I was living in Brooklyn and then
then
um, when
When I was 4
4 moved to Staten Island
Island. Umm, I lived
with my parents and
parents and brother and
I lived with
friends. Yeah. OK great, um, so
So why don't you begin with
with, umm
your disability, your stroke. When
When did it happen? How did it happen? Umm.
OK. Um, well, 2 years
ago. Um, I
I, um, I just thought. Now, I
I just thought I
was having, um, a
tired, umm
fever, um, stu-stuff
like that.
Um. This was
This was a progression of… Yes. Symptoms. Yes. I
see so it started with feeling tired and… Yes.
uh, Two months ago, I felt tired and, uh,
and, uh, umm, I felt tired
and feverish. 2 years ago? Yeah
Yeah, no. Two months ago? Yes.
Um, so, um I
I, I called a doctor, um
a Friday and, um,
I guess I've, uh, um
if, um, blood
test and, um, ok, um she
she said everything's
OK. Oh, good, ok. [laughs] And the next day
I had, uh, my stroke.
I called my mom
and called Jana
who I
I was supposed to be
going to her son's
son's birthday. And I don't, I didn't feel well, so
I was going to
rest. Um,
unbeknownst to Jana and my mom
uh, I have a stroke.
And what kind of a stroke? Um, I
I, uh, uh
That's ok
if you can, if you can't remember the name it'll. Isometric? No. Ischemic?
Yes, yes. Ok. Yes, ischemic, yes. And
this was just 2 months ago? No. 2 years. It was
2 years ago. 2 years ago. I
had thought, uh, 2 months ago
that, um, I wasn't feeling right
Oh, ok, I see. Ok, so the stroke was 2 years ago? Yes. Ok, and
while it was happening do you remember how you were feeling?
What was happening to you?
I remember. I remember [laughs]. I remember
watching
the, um, mystery,
uh, mystery
Um. A television show? Yes. Ok
Um. Watching TV? Yeah.
and, um, um, I
I feel like I was go, I don't know, I was
going out, like
um, 2
hours, uh, 3 hours, I don't know. And
I watched the television show. Which I, um
I, um, I, um, my
my head was down. I was watching a television show [laughs].
I don't know.
And you were out, passed out? Yeah. For a couple hours? Yes. And, and
and were you, were you alone? Yeah. And when you woke up, did you
did you dial 911? No, I couldn't because of. Your
you were already. Yes. So, what was the next step? Um,
my mom and dad
came they got the locksmith and they came into my apartment and, um, I was on the floor.
the locksmith and they came into my apartment, and, um, I was on the floor. And
you went
you went to the hospital. Yes. And
tell me what that was like waking up
um, in the hospital
after. Um. Did you have surgery, any type of surgery? No. Ok.
Um, I was rushed to
the hospital, um, and I
I wanted to talk but I couldn't. Wow
that must have been frightening. Yeah, uh, yeah
I guess, um, I had a stroke, yeah. I
I don't, uh, I guess, um, things
were fine, uh, well
rev-relatively fine on Saturday
and then I just learned I had a
stroke, yeah.
And were you
um, paralyzed anywhere
Uh. I'm. Besides your speech, besides
besides not being able to speak were you. I was, uh
uh paralyzed, uh, right arm
arm. Ok.Yeah.
And I don't know, yeah.
I'm sure you, you were in, um
um physical therapy? Yes. And. Physical. Speech
Speech therapy. Occupation and speech. Tell me about that experience. Um. Each of
those, if you mind. Yeah of course
Um, um, I
didn't get so much of the
OT, um, no, the
speech at
Cul-um, uh, Mount Sinai
I only was there like
fi-uh, 10 days
Um. I was at Burke
for 30 of them, no, uh,
I was at
Burke, uh, 30
of those days. And Burke is a rehabilition center? Yes, yes. Ok.
Um, I was, um, speech, um, I
I, I was, uh, I was
happy with the speech, um.
Fush-frustrated, but
happy. Uh, I, did, uh
a thing which
helps me say the words.
Mmhm. Um, yeah, so.
So you were happy with your progress? Yeah. But frustrated
Yes. Yeah I can imagine, I can't imagine actually.
What that's like. Thank you. What, what that's like.
Um, how did your family, um
react to your stroke and what kind of support did you get while you were
rehabilitating?
Uh, I guess my family gave
me
su- the support I needed. You were lucky they
live locally, too. Yes, yeah.
Um. They told me
um, they told
me to
get on, um, and
They were encouraging? Yeah. And supportive in. Yeah
Telling you to move on and. Yes. They, uh
that's great that they were able to be with you the whole time. Yeah, from Burke
and. Very lucky. Um, my,
Aunt and Uncle live in Larchmont. Oh ok. And they
they were staying with them.
Oh. wow so you had the whole mishpokhe there. Yeah, yes [laughs]. The whole
family. Oh yeah. [laughing] Um, that's great.
that's great.
Are you, um, do you
belong to any support groups or any kind of organizations? Yes, uh. That, that help you?
That, that help you? Yes, um.
As a matter
of fact NYU
has a support group, yeah.
I have liked that. And is that every week or. Uh, every, uh
every month. Once a month? Yeah. And, uh
you find the people in that group
are going through the same. Yeah. Things
that you're going through and. Yes. It's probably nice
to talk with other people. Yeah. Like that. So tell
what some of your biggest challenges are. What. What were some of the things
that you
that you had to overcome
um, after your stroke. Ok, um
um, let's see
word finding.
OK. Um, I
can't move my arm, but I'm going to get
there, um, hopefully
Great. Um, my
leg feels
good but not, um that good.
You have pain in your leg? No. Oh. I
just want
more. OK, understandable. So you have a limp?
Yes. I see, ok.
Well it must not be that bad, you don't have a cane. I know a lot of people that, that need a cane so
I guess. Thank you. In that respect
you're, you're lucky you're able to get around on your own. Yes
and, uh. Absolutely.
Yeah, um, so what, how did this
change, change your life. Did you have to stop working? Do you work now? Um, um, um two
Few years ago
ago. Um. Was
my last day of work. Um, today,
I'm going
going to, um, volunteer
at my school. Ohhh, that's excellent!
That's great. Yeah. So
so that's um, you've you've been
been uh asked back to volunteer, what you gonna be doing?
be doing?
Um. I don't know. [laughs] OK. What did you do before?
Um. Teacher. Teacher?
Um. Second grade teacher, and
and first grade teacher. OK. First and second grade teacher. Wow.
Wow. They were've love
Ah? Yes. [Laughs] Definitely.
So are you excited to be going back to Burke and do some. Um, I'm scared and exited.
Exited? Tell me a bit more about these feelings
Um. Scared, because
because, Um, scared because
I'm anxious. You know, um
Happy, because I am so glad, um, um,
So glad, yeah. Is it going to be
a few days a week, one day a week? Um, once a day a week. One day a week? Yeah
And, do you have any other volunteer jobs?
or opportunities that you or anything else that you participate in. Um, um,
Wednesdays and Fridays. I am
going to hopefully
Hopefully. Um, Um, Thursdays
and Fridays, I am gonna be
be
be. Um, working with
with and so
So going to be working with and for
for the NYU Speech. Um, yeah.
Oh OK so you're really really getting involved. Yeah. And doing well
Doing well of um
of um volunteer work.
CBOE, you don't know? Not familiar.Yeah, CBOE is
um in OT
Ok. Occupational therapy, um
it's like
like, um, um, it's
It's like,
It's like more
or less. Oh ok. Yeah and
And it's um, it opens up your hands.
Oh OK. And I'm going to be
doing that on October fourteenth.
OK and this, this will be your first small
Yes. OK if and is it
something
that happens, like automatically or is it something that you
have to
to wear every ? No. How does that work?
Fifteen minutes, No, forty five minutes a day.
Two times a day. Oh, ok.
OK. Yeah. You know I could catch
balls with it.
I see you're able to move you're arm a little bit. Thank you. That's great.
How you've been working with their therapist. Yeah.
A lot. Yeah.
So you'll get
there. Yeah, thank you. That's great.
How do you, how do you manage day to day with, you know,
know only having the use of one arm right. It must be really
really difficult. I mean to
to wash your hair, I mean I guess you can put your hair in a ponytail,
ponytail or anything. Tell me, you know what some of the biggest
biggest physical challenges are for you.
Well, opening a jar [laughs].Yea.
You know. I'm um pick up my hand slowly
slowly. Mmhm. You know
know there isn't, hopefully
Hopefully in
anything, I can do.
Wow you know that's so nice to hear, so refreshing to hear. Thank you.
Um. That's great. There's nothing you can't do. That's amazing.
Just takes a little more time. Yes.
yes correct. That's wow, it's great I just got the goosebumps.
Thank you. That's so nice to hear.
hear. Are you doing anything
to create awareness about stroke?
or, I mean
an advocate for research funds or are you involved in any of those types
types of activities?
Yeah, Avi
has taken me to Turow college.
And I'm hopeful going to Adelphi
Ivy Golden
who was um,
Um. Was, is he in your support group? Yeah.
Yeah. OK.
So you know him through the
the stroke support group. Yeah. OK, great.
Great. Avi is taking me
to Adelphi
Adelphi, hopefully on
October uh ninth.
And what. What's going to happen on October ninth?
So we go and we speak about
aphasia. Oh OK and to
the freshman?
Sophomore? or is it  anyone that wants to attend? Yeah.
Um.
Speech. We were speaking at a
speech.
at Turow college.
And I don't know
know what that's going to be like at
Adelphi. So, you don't know what to expect
OK, really sounds exciting though.
So, good luck with that. Thank you.
Um, So I want to speak a little bit about
about stroke and what it is exactly.
And you know
hopefully, help other people become aware of
You know the symptoms, and what you can do to prevent it or, while you're
having the stroke. What, you know, what exactly
causes it, what what happens in the body physically?
Well.
Migraines. Yes.
I get migraines
little. All
through my life. So I
didn't get that. But migraines.
I think.
Migraines. So you suffer
suffered through migraines? Friday,
Two years ago on Friday I was feeling icky
Icky.
But migraines. And you had a migraine?
Yup. So you just thought that it was a regular migraine. Yes, but
I didn't feel right.
In my
my speech got slurred.
My arm again
Again was weak
And I couldn't, couldn't move it.
And my leg, couldn't
Couldn't move. Well, I shouldn't say that
I'm. Hopefully. Yeah.
I couldn't move it.
Yeah. What were the reactions of
of your friends?
friends? Did they support you and help
you through with your, your speech homework
and
anything? Yes, Robin helped me
me tremendously.
She was exceptional.
Robin help me
with my speech homework
Robin is one of your good friends? Yes. OK.
Um.
Robin help me through my exercise
Yeah. So she is really there for you, supporting. Yes.
Supporting you, and helped you through
yeah, that's really that's really great that you have
someone. And, um Judy, who's um
My sister in law.
Helped me tremendously. And
Mark. Who's my brother. OK
And mom and dad helped me tremendously.
You know. So you have a lot of help.
That's good. Did you, when you were in the hospital, did you
Did you ever feel like you're going to die
die from now? No. You weren't afraid or
scared of that? No.
I asked that
because it's um, you know everyone's
stroke is different and their experiences
are different. I know someone had a really bad experience in
the
hospital. And I'm glad that you answered so emphatically
"No!" You sound really like you were really
are really brave and really strong and still
today. I'm inspired
by you. Thank you.
know. You know. I played over and over my head what you
said before,You can do everything you can do anything
it just takes a little more time.
And just a little more slowly. Yeah.
How
do you, can you remember a
time when your stroke
Really affected you but you were
determined not to let it get the best of you?
And it seems like all the time you don't let it um, you know
You know,overpower you. But is there one specific instance
instance that you can think of, and if not that's okay.
hey that's good if you can't think of something.
Well. I was
frustrated
with the word finding
finding
and how is that for you today? Are
you able to find the
words? Uh
a little bit. Little bit. And you're still working on it?
Working on that. Yea.
You'll get there someday. Thank you.
yes. Is there any
anything that you want to share that I
haven't covered. Anything you'd like to let the
community you know about stroke awareness?
or
any any
particular challenges that you
faced?
So I guess kind of wraps things up.
up here. You were very helpful. Thank you. Very very inspiring.
I think it's again, it's so great that you're able to
work with what you have and you feel you're just so brave
and you're like a role model. Aw, thank you.
So I want to thank you again for sharing your
experience. And that's about it, so thank you
you. Thank
you.